now let's get to Lori Lightfoot clay
Travis updated us on what happened last
night Lori Lightfoot was crushed in
tonight's Chicago Mayoral race and
didn't even make the runoff 84 percent
of Chicagoans voted against her 84 that
level of incompetence is tough to pull
off for an incumbent congrats to her I
mean it really is wild so there were
there were a bunch of people running but
the fact that 84 of the people said any
of these people instead of Lightfoot is
just really incredible I will say before
we get into some of Laurie's Greatest
Hits and her concession speech that I am
not hopeful for Chicago you know
generally what happens in these
democrat-run cities is they get rid of
you know they they vote in the most
radical person say a Gavin Newsom in San
Francisco or any of the DA's right
George gascon in in Los Angeles
Chester bonid and San Francisco Ted
wheeler mayor of Portland they vote in
the absolute absolute worst all hell
breaks lose crime runs rampant the the
good decent citizens law-abiding
citizens get the hell out of there
everybody's freaking out and then what
do they do they they either recall them
or they have another election and then
they just vote in someone slightly less
worse but not really less worse so I I
don't have much hope for Chicago which
is unfortunate Chicago was once an
absolutely wonderful City and when I was
did the book tour in Chicago we had an
absolutely great time Chicagoans have an
incredible sense of humor like they're
fun and light and it just really loved
it uh anyway uh here is just a bit of
Lori lightfoot's concession speech last
night
let me just uh do this
so thank you and and thank everyone so
much I feel a lot of love in this room
as I felt every step of the way on this
journey I've called Brandon Johnson and
Paul vallas to congratulate them on
their victories in advancing to the
runoffs
we were Fierce competitors
and these last few months but I will be
rooting and praying for our next mayor
to deliver for the people of the city
for years to come
okay so that part was actually kind of
nice and she's stepping down with a bit
of Grace uh but it did continue and we
got some information here from the New
York Post Democratic Chicago mayor Lori
Lightfoot blamed racism and her gender
for her Landslide defeat in her
re-election bid as Chicagoans wary of
rising crime on her watch celebrated her
fall from political rock star to Rock
Bottom I'm a black woman in America of
course she replied when asked by a
reporter if she'd been treated unfairly
but she called being Chicago's mayor the
honor of a lifetime the way that these
people use race and gender to their
advantage and is rather extraordinary
because the people voted her in so when
they voted her in were they racist
sexist bigots
it's only after a couple years of her
leadership that suddenly they became
racist sexist bigots because apparently
it's racist sexist bigots who don't like
mass murder on the streets constantly
[Music]
foreign